Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Da bin ich.
Heute war richtig gutes Wetter, ne?
Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ich war tatsächlich mal draußen.
Das soll vereinzelt, vereinzelt kommt das tatsächlich vor.
Und ich fürchte ja fast, ja ist echt so, Tribulan, ich fürchte zwar fast, dass ich dieses Jahr im Sommer vielleicht wieder sogar leichte Präunung habe auf der Haut.
Das war früher nie der Fall.
Aber aktuell ist es die letzten paar Jahre schon so gewesen, ich weiß gar nicht was da los ist.
What? CS, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich weiß gar nicht was da los ist.
Na los.
So, ups, jetzt habe ich den falschen Monitor.
Wahrscheinlich, heute musst du ja bei allem aufpassen.
So, also.
Ich habe eine Artikel gesehen von Microsoft.
Und zwar habe ich mir gedacht, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Und zwar das da.
Äh.
Nein.
Das war es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Das da.
Das habe ich gesehen und ich muss sagen, was ich Microsoft da ausgedacht habe, das ist jetzt zwar kein.
Keine weltbewegende Geschichte, aber das ist ganz cool.
Dann gucken wir uns mal an.
Es gibt so 5, 6 Sachen, die man sich angucken kann, aber.
Ist das mal, das ist, das ist.
Lass mich mal überlegen.
Jaja, das ist auf jeden Fall Mario Sunshine.
Ich glaube, das ist das.
Die Musik aus dem allerersten Level.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher.
Könnt ihr nachgucken?
Ja, ich glaube, das war das erste Level, oder?
Oh, Moment, Moment, hier, hier, das, das brauchen wir jetzt.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
So, und aber eine Sache muss man auch machen.
Bevor wir anfangen.
Aber eine Sache müssen wir noch machen bevor wir anfangen
Ich muss mir eine wobei habe ich habe ich vielleicht den test vm für so ein krempel weil die sache ist die das muss
So natürlich mit wishlist studio preview version und neuem dotnet core und hast du nicht gesehen als man guck mal ich habe
Warum ist das verschlüsselt
Bei dem song habe ich meine eltern ich dachte die haben sich bei der wee sport musik fest
Bei der bei der bei der wee sports musik kennengelernt
Bestimmt 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 oder cute chat continue
Hey 1 2 3 4 5 6 easy
Wir können die cute vm nicht nehmen weil wir brauchen wo ich das studio preview wir brauchen auf jeden fall
Irgendwas guck mal ich habe sogar schon den test vm wobei die ist wahrscheinlich old as fuck oder
Mal schauen mal schauen was wir hier mal schauen was wir hier haben
Windows
Professional okay also es ist auf jeden fall in windows 11 was wir hier haben
Wahrscheinlich müssen wir erst mal update machen und das dauert jetzt fünf stunden dann ist er nicht warum ist eigentlich windows update machen
gut 93 alles klar
Taugt windows elf was keine ahnung ich verwende kein windows elf
Ich habe das hier nur zum
testen mal installiert und das können wir wunderbar nehmen dafür warum dauert windows installieren eigentlich kürzer
als
windows update
Was moment heckermann hilfe wie gebe ich den genauen mannbereich von ls-l
äh
was
Du willst in die mannpage gucken was ls-l bedeutet oder was
Oder oder wie
Ich schon aufgefallen dass die google search bar anders ist nicht überall
Aber hier guckt mal heck weh die die search bar ist ein bisschen anders jetzt
Die search bar ist ein bisschen anders jetzt
Also
Also was ich machen würde ist ich mache die mannpage auf und wird dann nach minus l suchen
Also sagen wir mal so du kannst natürlich nach
Backslash minus l suchen weil dann findest du auch direkt minus l und nicht einfach nur minus l
Backslash minus l in der mannpage suchen slash drücken in der mannpage
slash
Ja, das ist das ist auch mega nice. Ja ja das ist auch das ist auch mega nice. Ja
Die reference when showing final formation for some reason
when showing final formation for symbolic link show information for the file link
reference ok also sprich wenn du ein link hast
Dann zeigt es dir für den link nicht an 777 wie das bei so ziemlich jedem link ist
Sondern es zeigt dir die richtigen rechte an der natei auf die der link zeigt
Verwende ich nie habe ich noch nie verwendet wüsste ich gar nicht wann ich das brauche
Aber ja das
Das ist anscheinend minus l
Ja, aber die seite ist wirklich pock
Wie geht das ich das kann sein dass man direkt suchen und mannpage öffnen kann in einem schritt weiß ich aber nicht
auch die musik ist zu laut
Schlecht abgemischte playlist alter lan
So da man sonst hier noch komme auch gleich c++ ab der ist ja hoffentlich nicht
Ich glaube es gibt kaum was schlimmeres was mich heute abend noch mehr schocken könnte
Als c++ update ich meine es gibt ja alle zwei jahre oder so neue c++ version
Aber es wird einfach nur noch nur noch immer beschissen haben die kriegen das nicht gebacken
wird immer wirrer
So mal gucken welche version von winners app was sind das hier was wollen die von mir ja ja remind me later easy
security so jetzt ist die frage
So jetzt ist die frage können wir das wirklich realistisch realistisch betrachtet updaten oder da
Also wenn ich chat wenn ich das jetzt was was was ist was macht es da wenn ich das jetzt mache
Das dauert doch drei stunden oder
Es ist egal
Was warum geht jetzt xbox auf was
Der was immer fort was will das von mir
Kann man das auch schließen irgendwie
Windows please kann ich kann ich das
Nein geh weg ich will das schließen wie mache ich das zu kann man das irgendwie weg machen
Ah hier close one drive meine güde was ein krempel
Windows
Reinstall ne reinstall braucht kein update oder die wenn du es neu zerlässt die haben doch wenn du ein tagesaktuelles iso nimmst
So woher weiß man jetzt wie lange das dauert
Ich meine ich kann ja muschel studio habe ich das nicht sogar schon drauf
Muschel studio installer nice
Was
Das brauche ich
Ich glaube das brauche ich für
Gucken wir uns das mal an also
Wir wollen uns dort net
Das heißt check out wishel studio ist
Latest dot net latest wishel studio ok alles klar
Ich blick da also also windows macht es echt kompliziert ja auf download gib ihm gib ihm mal gucken wie lange das update dauert
Vielleicht 19 so wishel studio enterprise ne das will ich nicht
Was brauche ich denn um das neue features zu testen check out post is now available also wishel studio 2022 brauche ich
Wishel studio download
Community ja was
Community jawoll gib her
Wishel studio da mach
Ja
Das
Mich regt
Das erste was ich merke was mich wieder an windows 11 nervt ist das hier unten gecrupt ist
Man kann das immer noch nicht ausschalten oder dass die das die icons gecrupt sind
Und wie kriege ich wie kriege ich vor allem text an die icons dran ich will dass es so aussieht
Ich will dass es so aussieht so
Dass ich dass ich die die dass ich im browser auch die zeile sehe und sowas
Geht das irgendwie taskbar behavior
Ne das ist das ist zu advanced sowas das das geht nicht ne
Das geht nicht
So ein müll alter
Microsoft please
So ich möchte wishel studio installieren
Und zwar
Der installer
Warum kann ich das fenster nicht verschieben
Und zwar
Keine ahnung den
Ja dot net desktop
Da können wir auch gleich mal
Vielleicht ausprobieren
Ok
Install wieviel festplattenplatz habe ich
Diesem ding hier eigentlich gegeben der vm
Oh
Na da bin ich mal gespannt angeblich
Plus 7g
Aber mal schauen mal schauen ob das
Bei 7g bleibt
Was willst du von mir microsoft
Ich will mich weder
Einloggen
Noch sonst was
Ich will einfach nur dass du ab
Was ist das was ist das für
Scam was ist das für einen scam
Was wollen die von mir
Was genau wollen die von mir
Überhaupt was was ich
Will mich nicht einloggen
Was was ist das für ein schreis alter
Ok update
Hat er jetzt die updates runtergeladen
Ok also
Also wahrscheinlich brauchen wir 10 min oder so bis
Da ist es schon wieder
Meine
Gute Microsoft fickt euch alter
Was ist das ich will mich nicht
Einloggen lass mich
In update wie moment
Die updates fehlen weil ich nicht
Ein Moment
Ich muss eingeloggt sein dass ich
Update kann
Wait a minute
Ist das so muss man
Eingeloggt sein um update zu können
Ist das neu
Ach ist das das insider build
Moment wie geht das nochmal
Win fair
Ist das ein insider build
Kann man irgendwie wieder opt outen
Aus dem insider
Insider insider
Insider
Wie opt oute ich denn da wieder
Meine
Das regt mich schon wieder
Insider
Ja ich meine
Dagegen erlag ich mich halt ein
Mal kurz raussuchen
Was man für den account braucht
Wie jetzt gehts oder
Hä
Ich bin doch jetzt auch nicht eingeloggt
Also ganz ehrlich
Ich verstehe den kram nicht
Das Windows Zeug ist mir eindeutig zu hoch
Alles klar
Wunderbar jetzt funktioniert
Der kram ist auch 50% fertig
Wie opt out
Disable Windows
Insider
Ach so wenn das nächste
Release kommt
Okay
Das bringt
Das bringt mir schon mal gar nichts
Ich will das
Insider Preview eigentlich gar nicht
Ich will ein ganz normales
Windows 10
Nee Windows 11
Leute ich installiere das neu
Das dauert doch jetzt wieder 5 Stunden
Und dann funktioniert es am Ende nicht
Ich bin jetzt auf dem Internet
Auf der anderen Seite
Wir können es da durchlaufen
Ich meine es dauert noch 5 Minuten oder so
Dann sehen wir es ja ob es funktioniert
Oh Mann
Das ist ja ganz ätzend
Wenn ich Windows 11 sehe
Fühle mich belästigt
Das Problem ist halt
Das manche Sachen die ich machen will
Nicht unter Linux machen kann
Einfach Steam anschalten und was spielen
Ist halt ein bisschen schwieriger
Am besten ist
Das nervigste unter Windows
Das rumgegängelt die ganze Zeit
Arrow
Dankeschön für den Sub
Das ist wirklich grausam
Ganz schlimm
Bei dir ruckelt
Hast du 3D Beschleunigung eingeschaltet
Du musst hier hin
Gülle
Ich muss sagen Accelerate 3D Graphics
Dann hast du Glück
Dann läuft es ein bisschen besser
Wobei so wirklich
Super krass läuft es eh nicht
Vielleicht jetzt nicht mehr
Nachdem ich 5x abbrechen gedrückt habe
Ich glaube ich muss
Reinstallen gleich
Die Vmware Tools
Die brauchst du auf jeden Fall
Das ist richtig
Das ist korrekt
Vmware Tools musst du installieren
Sonst funktioniert es jetzt nicht
Install Error
Meine Güte
Microsoft
Vielleicht muss ich Windows
Auch gar nicht updaten
Und kann einfach Visual Studio
Und das neue.NET draufhauen
Downloaden wir das doch schon mal
Wo sind wir denn
C-Sharp 11 Features
Und jetzt was brauchen wir für
Meine Augen
Hilfe
Flashbang
Boah
Ich kann nicht hingucken
Mir wird schlecht
Ok
Windows
Mehr braucht man glaube
nicht oder
Ja gut
Web Anwendungs Sachen machen wir
Die.NET Desktop Runtime
Ah ne
Das SDK ist ja alles dabei
So installieren wir das mal
Dark Reader das ist eine Vm
Da hab ich keinen Dark Reader drauf
Also ich hab den Installer angeklickt
Aber da geht anscheinend
Ah doch jetzt
Was ich auch witzig finde
Man sieht hier halt den Installer halt
Dass die schon aus unterschiedlichen Generationen kommen
Das ist richtig uralt Oldschool Installer
Das ist irgendein Web-Based
Elektron Installer, die benutzt ja nicht mal
ihren eigenen Scheiß. Wieso nutzt du Chrome
Warum nicht
Das ist eine Vm zum Zeug ausprobieren
Ich hab alles mögliche drauf
Aber anscheinend ist Chrome aktuell Default
Install Error ok ich glaub wir haben's geschafft
So Visual Studio ist drauf
.NET ist auch drauf
Vielleicht müssen wir Windows gar nicht mehr updaten
Einfach auch so
Gebt der Kiste ein Reboot
Oh da hab ich Schiss da kann ich mich nicht mehr einmelden
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich die einmal Rebooted hab
Not now, maybe later
Dark
Scheint
Warum wird man eigentlich überall so
krass gegängelt
Das wieso würde
mich interessieren
Ich hab doch alles mögliche drauf
Chrome ist halt aktuell Default
Normalerweise verwende ich
Chrome, Chromium und Firefox
Alles
Alles mögliche
Und ich hab's
In der Regel so
verteilt
Dass ich
YouTube und sonstige
Gedöns
Hab ich in Firefox
Homeoffice
Kram hab ich in Chrome
Und zum normalen
Browsen verwende ich
Chromium
So das ist die normale Verteilung
Was ist das für ein Packet Tracer Projekt
Ich glaube
Was war das für ein Packet
Tracer Projekt
Ich glaube wir haben
nicht den BGP
Internetausfall
von der Telekom
Warum gibt's das
Hier eigentlich 50 mal drinne
Ich muss mal kurz gucken was das war
Homeoffice auf dem Streaming Rechner
Ich hab nur einen Rechner
Ich hab keinen Homeoffice Rechner
Ich hab einen Vorschau Rechner
Das ist mein alter
Auf dem zweiten Monitor da wo ich euch jetzt gerade drauf sehe
Seit wann muss man sich da einloggen
Und wie haben wir das das letzte mal benutzt
Wenn ich das direkt öffnen
Dann geht's vielleicht
Warum ist alles mittlerweile so
Abfuck Account zwang
Ganz ehrlich Leute was ist das denn für
Eine Kacke Du kannst nichts mehr verwenden
Ohne 30 Milliarden Accounts überall zu haben
Vor allem warum
Das hat überhaupt keinen Mehrwert warum muss das alles
Wenn ich das direkt öffnen
Dann geht's vielleicht
Ja
Das war wo man den BGP
Diese
BGP Probleme die
Die Telekom mal hatte letztes Jahr
Haben wir nachgebaut
Ich bin mir da aber nicht mal sicher um was es da genau ging
Ich kann mich nur noch dunkel dran erinnern
Wir können uns
Einen Fake Account machen aber trotzdem warum
Warum ist das überhaupt notwendig
Hey Leute ich hätte mal eine
Frage wenn man Programmieren lernen will
Wenn man Programmieren lernen will gibt es unzählige
Quellen im Internet wo fängt man am besten an
Wenn man mehr wissen mit dem ganzen Netzwerkzeug
Will was ja viel damals
Auch im Stream thematisiert wo ich dann nichts verstehe
Also ist die Frage was du machen willst
Netzwerkzeug ist jetzt vielleicht nicht die beste
Variante zum Anfang mit
Programmieren das beste ist
Du schnappst dir einen Text Editor
Und einen Browser und fängst an mit Javascript
CSS, HTML
Wenn du sonst nichts genaueres vor hast
Weil
Also wenn du sonst keine genaueren Vorstellungen hast
Weil Frontend brauchst du immer
Egal was du machst kommst du nie dran vorbei
Und
Du siehst auch direkt was passiert
Dann will ich Programmieren lernen
Ach so
Ach du meinst
Ah jetzt hab ich's verstanden
Wenn du Netzwerkgeschiss lernen willst
Programmieren gibt's viel
Aber Netzwerkgedöns gibt's nicht
Ok
Ok jetzt hab ich's verstanden
Das ist in der Tat eine gute Frage
Ich hab damals
Glück gehabt
Ich hab meine Ausbildung bei einem Provider
gemacht und da hat man zwangsläufig
Relativ viel
Netzwerkzeug gelernt
Und was der
QY Packet Tracer ist besser
Das ist doch bestimmt irgendein Fork vom Packet Tracer
Oder
Irgendwie China-Chinesen-Klon
Also wie gesagt
Ich hab meine Ausbildung beim Provider gemacht
Das heißt da musste man sich zwangsläufig
mit ein bisschen Netzwerkgramms beschäftigen
Und
Deswegen weiß ich da jetzt auch heute
noch die ganzen Basics Sachen
Zum größten Teil
Tja
Aber ansonsten wie man das am besten so
Just for fun lernt
Wenn man nicht gerade
Ausbildung macht
Ist ne gute Frage, ich weiß nicht was es für gute
Kanäle gibt für Netzwerkgrundlagen
Das CCNA Buch finde ich nicht
Gut. CCNA ist viel zu
Cisco spezifisch
Da lernst du Cisco Kommandozeilenbedienung
Aber was man hier lernen muss ist ja sowas
Wie zum Beispiel
Was sind IP-Adressen? Warum gibt's
MAC-Adressen? Was hat das mit
Abauf sich und solche Geschichten
Musst du ja lernen
Da bringt
CCNA jetzt nicht so viel außer du willst
Alles in der Cisco Welt wissen
So
Mein Desktop sieht viel zu clean aus
Ja das ist ja auch nicht der richtige Desktop
Das ist ja nur der VM Desktop
Mein richtiger Desktop ist so wie sich das gehört
Heute war wieder ein BGP
Hijack
Wirklich?
Ernsthaft wo?
Warum findet man dazu nichts?
Die Russen haben Twitter versucht zu übernehmen
Wirklich?
Du hast ein Link geschickt
Das da?
Twitter war bei mir für ca.
45 Minuten ausgefallen
Wer ist das?
Okay, irgendjemand
Der schreibt Bitcoin und Krypto
Auf seinem Profil, ich weiß nicht
Ist Gbaited?
Das heißt ja nicht
Das ist irgendein BGP-Gedünt
Und zwar
Was hat man Traffic
Vom deutschen Festnetz zu Twitter
Beim größten russischen Mobilfunkanbieter zu suchen?
Vielleicht ist der Traffic in Russland grad billig
Ich meine, das kann durchaus sein
Aha
Guck mal da
BGP Hijack
Präfix
Okay, da muss besser sein
Was ist das?
Okay, da muss man jetzt gucken
Welche Netze das sind
Interessant
Die Russen
Gekommnets am Start
Our traffic now
Das ist diese Big Brain Seite
Wo man das nachvollziehen kann, oder?
Ja, genau
Hier
Beginning
Präfix
Ist normalerweise auf Twitter
Aber am Beginn
Der gleiche Präfix
Ist auch auf ASN
Okay, wer ist das?
Aha, rtkomm.ru
Alles klar
Our traffic now
Verstehe
Da mach ich morgen ein Video zu
Ein spannendes Thema
Sus
Ja, richtig Sus
Was? Das für Netzwerkvideos?
Okay, zeig mal her
Sebastian Philipp
Eigene Route Zertifikate erstellen
Oh
Der macht wirklich Netzwerkzeug
Und
Oh nee, der macht richtig Hardcore Sachen
Alles klar
MonkaS
Aber siehst du vor, dass der Plan hat
Das sehe ich alleine schon an den Thumbnails
Das der Ahnung hat
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das ist
So
Also, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Geht unser Windows jetzt? Ja
Chat, was meint ihr?
Soll ich nochmal rebooten vorher?
Ich reboote nochmal
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob das alles sonst funktioniert
Restart
Ja, gerade deswegen
Weil es random build aus dem Video ist
Und das random build aus dem Video sieht aus
Wie aus dem Video von jemand, der weiß, was er sagt
Ich reboot mal
Und dann gucken wir uns mal ein paar neue C-Sharp-Features an
Zu einem ordentlichen E-Mail-Provider gehen
Der ordentlichen Anti-Spam macht
Oder selbst den Kram blocken
Wenn es immer das gleiche Monster ist
Das ist dein Netzwerktechniklehrer gewesen
Ich hätte auch gerne gehabt, dass mein Netzwerktechniklehrer YouTube Videos macht
Entwickelst du C-Sharp unter Linux?
Ja, normalerweise schon
Aber man muss diese Previewsachen
eigentlich unter Windows testen
Das geht nicht anders
Du brauchst irgendein neues Visual Studio
Das Preview läuft auch unter Linux
Aber neueste Visual Studio Sachen gibt's halt nur unter Windows
Ich glaub' noch nicht mal für Mac
Ich glaub'
Ja, Umut, was willst du mir damit sagen? Ich weiß nicht, wer das ist
Es ist super nervig, dass man mehr oder weniger Rider bei Linux braucht
Warum Rider? Ist doch richtig geil
Ganz davon abgesehen
Alter
Warum?
Windows
Sind die Russen bei mir
auf Windows oder ist das normal unter Windows 11?
Was geht denn hier ab?
Teams haben wir auch installiert
Quit
Alles, alles weg
Ich will jetzt alles, alles deaktivieren
Alles weg
Der ganze Scheiß
Oh
Ich krieg' Anfälle unter Windows, was ist das?
Das ist ganz normal
Ich vermute, ich vermute auch, dass das normal ist
Okay
Schauen wir mal
Das sind die Amis nicht, die Russen, okay
Ja
Kannst du mal, also so genau
Warum ich das nicht unter Linux teste ist
Weil Rider mit den Features nicht ganz so schnell ist
Gerade bei Preview-Versionen
Kannst du mal eine Video machen, wo man auf das QNAP
Oder Terratech Linux
Als Haus installiert
Die einen HDMI Anschluss haben
Was?
Also ich hab' weder ein QNAP
Noch ein Terratech
Ich vermute mal, dass das auch ein NAS Hersteller ist
Keine Ahnung
Äh, das kann ich nicht zeigen
So
Also, continue
Create New Project
Schauen wir uns das doch mal an
Warum ist denn das so viel?
Wo
Jetzt mal
Wo wählt man denn
Wo wählt man denn in Whistle Studio überhaupt die
.NET-Version aus? Ich hab' das so lange nicht verwendet, man
Ah, hier, nee
Ja
Ah, hier
.NET 6, nee
Ich will.NET 7 haben, ich hab' doch
.NET 7 installiert
Äh
Warum kann ich nicht
Warum kann ich nicht.NET 7 auswählen?
Sekunde, hat das
Hat das mit dem Installieren nicht funktioniert?
Wo
.NET 7
also so einfach so einfach starten geht anscheinend nicht die templates der
projekte sind noch nicht vorhanden ok also was müssen wir machen check out
is now available find out was you announced to learn ja wie verwendet man
den kram denn jetzt also dort ein bild bla bla bla
habe ich denn habe ich dann habe ich denn das neu dass das neu genug neust
genug wichelt studio wie ich brauche doch das preview hier steht doch dass du 7.1
brauchst und das ist doch 7.1
das ist doch
das ist 7.1
muss ich jetzt wirklich muss ich ernsthaft noch die preview version
installieren jetzt
warum ist eigentlich die version von c++ die zahlen des jahres oder bei c sharp
halt irgendwas anderes ja weil dies bei c plus plus dieses c plus plus cremium
festlegt und bei bei c sharp und dort net microsoft die haben sich halt was
anderes ausgedacht also noch mal installieren jetzt oder wie
jetzt nicht ernsthaft oder
912 workloads ja and workloads gibt gibt mir
in workload wo die standardsachen drin sind hier da install was geht ich war
in das frage ich das müsste bei microsoft fragen gleich mein pc voll
wahrscheinlich so oder aber wir probieren es jetzt mal aus während der während der
krempel hier installiert probieren wir mal aus ob wir nicht ein projekt anlegen
können und das dann automatisch ändern auf eine neue dort net version so also
console ab jawoll next dort net 6
ach du bist lange nicht gesehen wie sieht es aus auf watch 2 willst du die
beta angucken im april kuckst du die beta an
hallo
ach jetzt geht es doch oder was boah das ist so schlecht mann alter das ist so
schlecht ok also ihr meint wirklich ich brauche die version ja dann warte ich
schnell bis die version installiert es geht ja jetzt habe ich ich kann das mal
ausprobieren macht man das unter studio eigentlich kann man hier die version
einstellen
ich klicke nicht auf irgendwelche random links
ach doch da ok ja doch ich habe doch drauf verwende das was verwenden der
vorschau version des dort net sdk starten erforderlich boah da wäre ich im leben
nicht drauf gekommen moment wo ist das nicht account settings
wind moment tools options ist das war das ist super versteckt ok jetzt hier
revue revue features use preview windows fahrer
ah hier restart
und jetzt sollte es doch eigentlich funktionieren was wollen die mich heute
komplett verarschen oder was klappt geht da überhaupt irgendwas ist da
irgendwas lauffähig bei diesem ganzen dreck das ist ja der wahnsinn heute das
ist ja komplette zumutung mann
du startest eine fahr informatiker ausbildung anwendungsentwicklung pock
nice pausiert doch die installation ich sehe das nicht ein warum kann das nicht
einfach parallel funktionieren ich installiere was komplett anderes
announcing dotnet 6 fastes dotnet jett alles klar bei microsoft erinnert ihr
euch noch an die windows 95 98 2000 was auch immer installer windows was auch
immer setze versionen des jahres ein ist das beste windows dass es je gab
akira sagt ich habe die ausbildung zum game und multimedia entwickler
absolviert findet kein job feels batman
du bist gehyped auf die overwatch später ich bin ja mal gespannt ich bin mir
immer noch nicht sicher ob ich mir das das gerätsche noch mal an an tun werde
so und jetzt selbst fertig aha
nein
ich ich will nicht sein innen
das jahres linux des tops ja das werden wir nicht so schnell sehen
höchstens höchstens in wsl form ok krei das ist jetzt die preview version oder
ok next next
aha der windows explorer bekommt ads wirklich das habe ich noch nicht gelesen
moment wirklich wirklich mal das muss ich mir angucken
windows explorer werbung pc welt alter pc welt
dann die komplett den arsch offen oder was
das ist werbung oder was hier oben
das ist quasi die werbung das ist so ein dregshaufen dieser sind also wenn also
man kann sich über microsoft wirklich streiten die haben die letzten jahre
durchaus viele gute sachen gemacht mit github machen sie weiter gute sachen
mission studio code ist gut die ganze open source geschichte mit dort net ist
gut da sage ich gar nichts aber windows ist ein einziger clusterfuck absoluter
wahnsinn also windows ist wirklich die größte heißeste scheiße die
microsoft einfach zu bieten hat kein wunder microsoft will ja selbst ja
nichts mehr mit zu tun haben anscheinend so haben wir jetzt dort net sieben
projekte hat es jetzt funktioniert ja ja schauen wir mal
konsole readline ist sie klar und läuft da was
ja ja ok ich glaube wie geht man überhaupt in einem jemanden planen wie
man in einem was ist das hier überhaupt was ist das für komische
high fat auto vervollständigung die ich hier habe ist das ist das github
copilot oder was ist das da standardmäßig an oder was ist das für
zeug was ich hier sehe haben jetzt haben die github code pilot standardmäßig an
ich konnte co-pilot co-pilot für arme in telecode ok also jetzt gucken wir uns
mal an was gibt es denn für super ich will nicht den explorer aufmachen ich
möchte möchte chrome aufmachen ich brauche dark reader dark reader chrome
sekund ich kann es nicht konnte man die microsoft seite nicht selbst irgendwie
auf dark schalten ging das nicht irgendwo hatten die nicht irgendwann
switch dafür wahrscheinlich nur die nur die die doko seiten
dark reader chrome halte ich sonst nicht aus dass ich er blinde ja meine netzhaut
brennt auch auf microsoft mach hin please lasst euch nicht so lange feiern in
rettmund ok
da krüder so viel besser viel besser viel besser
kitzscher bevor wir anfangen ich gucke noch mal kurz in den chat ob ich
irgendwas übersehen habe das ist jetzt schlecht wenn doch das g steht für sehr
gut man macht das l macht das l das ist besser
da kannst du noch eine überleitung zu linox machen
ja nice so schön ich du bist nicht der erste der das erzählen ich finde das
immer cool wenn ich so jetzt im nachhinein so zehn jahre später teilweise
sehe dass leute wegen ihrer ausbildung gemacht haben und leute damit happy sind
heute das hätte ich damals nie gedacht dass das mal wirklich jemand macht weil
ich das gesagt habe oder so aber der witz ist ja die leute die damals also
die fortnight community quasi von 2010 das war halt damals nicht fort fort
night das waren quasi ganzen battlefield kinder die haben bei mir die videos
geguckt nicht battlefield call of duty kinder die haben bei mir die videos
geguckt und die ganzen call of duty kinder 13 14 15 die sind heute halt
einfach mal 25 26 kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen oder
ich suche ich suche aber gemittel meiner freie betriebssystem aber aus das
ganze ja das ist wahnsinn bei uns ist es so sie wollten dass wir zwangsläufig
finde aus verwenden aber wir haben uns jetzt lange genug davor gedrückt und ich
habe letztens mit dem kollege eine vortrag drüber gehalten dass wir halt
nicht mit wind ausgescheit arbeiten können so wie es jetzt ist jetzt
bekommen wir wieder den kisten oder was heißt bekommen wir haben sie ja immer
noch
ja wie gesagt ich weiß schon dass das ungefähr so ist weil es ist noch klar
die leute damals sind die die heute fortnight gucken 13 14 15 16 vielleicht
das war die die damals call of duty geguckt haben heute ist es quasi zehn bis
zwölf jahre später das heißt die leute sind heute so irgendwas von 22 bis 28
so jetzt gucken wir uns den kram aber an was wo ist meine tagsgleiste hin was
können die überhaupt mann was ist das für ein rotz so also jetzt jetzt ich
bin ja eigentlich nur für sie scharpe features jetzt zum glück muss ich sie
scharpe nicht unter wind aus programmieren zum glück
ich würde ja anfälle bekommen also wishel studio selber geht ja noch das ist
gar nicht so wild habe ich früher auch viel benutzt aber aber windows ein gut
ich weiß auch schon dass ich ich werde windows 10 ich meine ich bin auch kein
großer 10 fern oder so ich werde wenn ich die wenn ich diesen bullshit jetzt
sehe ich werde aus sehen bis zum letzten update bis bis zum letzten nicht update
sondern bis zum letzten quasi end of life update durchziehen es sei denn es
kommt gibt bis dahin wenn aus 12 und wenn aus 11 ist nicht mal so ätzend
wishel studio 22 ist der größte dreck
gott geht am start schild fliegt dage für den sub ja deswegen also man kann ja
rider nach sagen dass es langsam ist in manchen fällen ja ok aber abkacken tut
eigentlich ich glaube ich hatte noch nie einen wirklichen rider crash darf man
links posten ja so lange es keine tost links sind tost links postet man nur
einmal mod check so also die seinen sich ab 11 bla bla bla bla was haben wir
sonst hier schönes neues uninteressant also sich ab 11 preview allow new lines
in den löchern gatschi bass auf interpolated strings
ihr benutzt rein aber ein schneller ist als wishel studio mit
resharper ja resharper stimmt das ist ja auch von denen damit haben die mal so
so angefangen es war so eines der ersten dinger ich kann mich noch dran
erinnern wie scharpe hatte ich früher auch resharper hatte ich mal so 2000
fragt mich nicht fünf oder so
es gibt auch resharper für c++ bei c++ hilft schärfen nix bei c++ muss
quasi neu machen dass es was taugt die musik zu laut
ok also in den löchern von interpolated strings dürfen wir jetzt new lines machen
also quasi so was hier ok so was ist jetzt erlaubt ja im moment das ist ja
fake dass das das kann er so dann funktionieren also zum beispiel so was
wie war gleich 1000 oder so und da darf ich jetzt quasi new lines rein machen
oder wie
ach nee moment das ging nämlich schon immer ich darf jetzt hier new lines rein
machen oder wie also ich darf jetzt sekunde wenn ich das richtig verstehe
warum geht der explorer auf habe ich explorer gedrückt ich darf moment nee
das wiss wenn ich irgendein objekt habe dann darf ich zeilen umbrechen also so
was hier zum beispiel
alles funktioniert nicht
das funktioniert aber gar nicht ach moment das ist c sharp 10 den der soll
11 verwenden wo macht man das language version ach nee das muss man das muss
man hier oben hier oben machen wie die das gesagt haben ok cs proj feil wie ging
das noch mal close projekts anlaut
und jetzt so was hier
warum warum taget network 6 7 7 sollen jetzt laden jetzt und jetzt ist man
syntax highlighting kaputt nee funktioniert ach guckt mal jetzt
funktioniert das ok also sprich ich darf jetzt hier new lines rein machen ok
ok ich glaube das ist wirklich gar nicht so schlecht
guckt mal zum beispiel also eine sache nur nur eins keine ahnung war list gleich
ok mal hier feifei feifei autopilot also ich könnte ich könnte zum beispiel so
was man hier list select irgendwie sowas hier keine ahnung die größer fünf
mal mal in oder nee nee quatsch nicht select ist der schwachsinn wer select plus
fünf keine ahnung ok das das wäre jetzt erlaubt und das wäre in dotnet das
wäre in c sharp 10 noch nicht erlaubt gewesen ich muss sagen so wirklich geil
zu lesen ist es nicht also ich weiß nicht kann man das auto formatieren lassen
irgendwie ich mein wenn wenn schon sollte man es vielleicht so schreiben
also wenn wenn schon dann dann so aber ok
aber gucken ob das jetzt wenigstens funktioniert
eigentlich hätte ich jetzt also ich gebe ich gebe ja gar nichts aus
null gibt ja gar nichts aus ach nee moment das funktioniert ja so gar nicht
das ist ja die liste das ist ja immer noch das ist ja das ist ja immer noch
eine eine neue liste oder neues innumerable was rauskommt ich kann ich
darf noch nicht mal tool to string machen nee to string bringt nichts ich muss
machen string join das wird das wird abartig separator keine ahnung coma und
jetzt die liste und jetzt wieder zumachen das sieht schon massiv hässlich
aus oder count ist 11 12 13 14 ja das passt das sieht aber schon nicht nicht
hübsch aus jetzt muss ich mal sagen ich war mir könnten jetzt noch ein bisschen
einrücken dass man weiß es bezieht sich auf die liste ja also ich denke mal das
ist so ein feature wenn man das mal brauche ist es nice dass es da ist aber
ich habe es glaube auch gerade mit dem chat geschrieben ich habe es bisher jetzt
nur nicht vermisst aber ok es auf jeden fall nicht schlecht dass es geht
das macht man außerhalb vom string interpolieren ja aber neues feature in
c sharp 11 ist du kannst es auch im string interpolieren machen
ja eben normalerweise könnte man auch so was machen hier keine ahnung result
gleich so jetzt ist mal ordentlich einrücken lassen
anweschen studio eigentlich das komplette dokument das komplette dokument
reformatten irgendwie geht das anscheinend ich oder
was control k control x ist in so snippet control k control d der ist der
meinung es gibt nichts zum reformatieren
eindeutig nichts zum reformaten ja klar ob obviously nichts zum reformaten
ja ich meine so könnte man schreiben so ich schenne das ging die ganze zeit
schon was man jetzt machen darf ist das da aber es ist nicht so als wir das sind
sinnvoll ja ja machen wir es mal rückgängig
weil das ist jetzt neu ok nice nicht dass ich es gebraucht hätte
extension die uns sehr formatiert ja die ist der meinung es gibt hier nichts zu
formatieren es ist alles alles das ist fein sagt studio ok also das ist hier
poggers poggers feature nummer eins alles klar nice nice to have wirklich
essentiell ist es jetzt nicht so was schreiben die sonst noch dazu nö das wars
preview list pattern oh jetzt wird es advanced wahrscheinlich was für die
ganze list programmierer unter uns
gibt es eigentlich echt kein video wo du dein liniung setup zeigst video glaube
ich nicht aber es gibt ein paar streams wo wir das zusammen eingerichtet haben
muss man schiefgucken ich meine es ist schönes liniung setup hier was ich gerade
habe oder kap
ich schaue mal kurz in in chat ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe
sieh nicht so aus wenn irgendwas ist mal schreibt entwuppler dabei
dokter hau mich blau danke für den sub ich habe wieder die hälfte übersehen
an subscriptions ja ich glaube der sound geht wieder nicht für subscriptions also
wen habe ich denn übersehen doch der hau mich ist am schall unic
ist auch wieder am start wapnick chillfreak steinadler error od
wort cs dankeschön leute heute für die ganzen subs thx ck 400 danke für den
sub
ok nice also was haben wir dann was haben wir dann sonst noch als nächstes list
patterns read more about this change in the proposal list patterns ne proposals
les ich nicht die sind immer 50 seiten lang
hier das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so lang also was kann man jetzt hier machen
pattern 1 2,0.10
ich glaube
oh jetzt wird es 8 du scheiße monka es ok das müssen wir das müssen wir
gerade mal ein bisschen das muss man ein bisschen auf aufsplitten also erstes
feature haben wir ausprobiert mal weg also er hat das müssen eins eins zwei
drei nennen sonst das ja nicht so und jetzt kann man was machen
warte ein minuten was
moment
ok der checkt jetzt ob das array diese muster entspricht also da muss ich keinen
check man das kann ich auch mit einem if verwenden wenn ich das richtig sehe also
sprich ich kann auch sagen if das war array eins
ob wir verwenden das jetzt ist ok cool und jetzt und jetzt bin ich gespannt
kann ich sowas hier sagen war b dieser bade das funktioniert nicht oder muss ich
das muss ich das dahinter machen moment funktioniert das wirklich
ok das ist ziemlich krass das ist das ist nice ich also mir fällt jetzt
spontan nicht so die die ultra anwendungs gebiete ein aber ich glaube
wenn man das braucht kann einem das sehr viel drumherum gebastel ersparen wie
gesagt die ganze lisp fans werden sich freuen wahrscheinlich also sprich ich
kann jetzt checken in einem guck mal das ist das ist cool ich kann jetzt in einem
if checken ob dieses array erstens nicht nulles zweitens ein array ist oder naja
was heißt denn ein ray irgendwas innermarable mäßiges wahrscheinlich ist
wobei vielleicht funktioniert es auch nur für erase
müsste man mal gucken ich will jetzt dafür drauf tippen das funktioniert für
jedes innermarable aber vielleicht funktioniert es auch nur für erase
müssen wir gleich mal in den in den blog beitrag gucken
so ich kann jetzt checken ob es nicht null ist ich kann checken ob es ein
interesse oder ein ein array mit mit zahlen auf jeden fall und ich kann im
klein und und ich kann checken entspricht das array diese muster also sprich
fängt es mit 12 an in elementen 0 und 1 hört es mit 10 auf und alles in der
mitte kann ich mir in eine temporäre variabel schreiben lassen
ok das ist schon extra big brain zeug so und das heißt im endeffekt auch die
ausgabe wenn ich das jetzt hier richtig richtig sehe die ausgabe müsste jetzt
eigentlich sein 2 ne null die ausgabe müssen das ist ja durf wir machen mal
array array 3 kommt nichts was raus also die ausgabe müsste jetzt sein 5 6 7 8
9 mit comma getrennt wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe ich habe das
nicht richtig verstanden leute ich hätte eigentlich gedacht es gibt eine
ausgabe ach rietlein muss nach unten ja doch 5 6 7 8 9 passt doch 5 6 7 8 9 ok
das ist das ist das ist cool ich bin mir noch ich bin mir noch über den
anwendungszweck nicht so ganz im klaren aber es ist nice
moin mir wurde die tage was mir wurde die tage der letztes video vorgeschlagen
seitdem habe ich gefallen am digitalen putter ich kann dich schon vor zehn
mal durch den krieg aber als früher ps3 fanboy war so damals für mich als ich
war nicht pc spieler ich habe auf der xbox gespielt jetzt aber vielleicht
als ps fanboy noch schlimmer pc ist ja immer noch so neutral aber xbox war ja
quasi der feind
scheiß wix box man und heute ist beides müll
kannst du den generierten code von dem noch anschauen von was
tschüss mein name hatte geschrieben ich glaube es wird mal ein stream mit funktionalen
sprachen vor mir ist rast rast funktional genug mehr brauche ich
nicht den generierten code hier von ja den können wir uns tatsächlich
anschauen probieren wir das mal aus testen wir mal schabl ab mal gucken ob
die schon previews drin haben bin ich mir gar nicht sicher wenn er sich kennt
schabl ab ist eine richtig nice seite da bekommt man seinen dotnet code bekommt
man übersetzt in ihr gut je nachdem was man haben will in das was dass die
schab compiler draus macht oder in intermediate code oder in sampler ich
will haben mein ne next
haben die das haben die das hier schon
nee wir brauchen überhaupt von 2022
Ich
bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, was er für Schmerzen hat, aber...
Das ist anscheinend gerade noch broken. Du hast nur den halben Code kopiert.
Nö, ich habe alles, was man braucht. Oder? Ich habe alles, was man braucht.
Aber das sollte doch jetzt kompilieren.
Nö, das ist kaputt. Das ist kaputt. Keine Chance. Können wir uns gerade nicht angucken.
Broken IF. Ich glaube, da müssen wir ein paar Tage warten, bis das wieder gefixt ist.
Ich meine, wir können uns IL-Spy installieren und das...
Ja, gibt es in Wishill Studio eine IL-Ansicht? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber wir können uns in die Compiler IL-Spy...
Aber hier JET-BRAINS-TOOLBOX.
Nö, IL-Spy. Gibt es den in der Toolbox überhaupt?
DN-Spy, den kenne ich gar nicht. Wo gibt es den?
Ah, GitHub. Der ist outdated.
Outdated, overrated, jebaited. Wir installieren mal die Toolbox.
Vielleicht können wir auch Rider verwenden. Auf Windows. Komm, gib mal alles. Gib Gas.
Mach nicht so lahm. Das Ding ist poggers. Okay.
So, dann gucken wir uns mal an, was da für IL-Code bei rumkommt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Toolbox überhaupt IL-Spy installieren kann.
Ja, ja. Nein, wir wollen keine IL-Spy.
Hier will ich hin. Was ist das schon wieder? Windows.
Alter, Windows, hör auf mich so abzufucken. Was ist das?
Alter, dieses Drecks-Tool, man. Ich hasse Windows so sehr. Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich nicht an JET-BRAINS, das liegt wahrscheinlich an Windows.
Hat hier irgendjemand IL-Spy, Leute? Ah, nee. Ich meine nicht IL-Spy.
Ich meine.peak. Ich meine nicht IL-Spy..peak ist doch von denen.
Jetzt habe ich mich vertan. Nicht IL-Spy..peak, meine ich.
Open..peak-Toolbox. So, wie kann man den Kram jetzt starten?
So, bin. Die Bug. Ist das so mega langsam?
Guckt euch das mal an, man. Ist das so wie JV-peak?
Genau. Moin, Serious Max. Poggers Urlaub, so muss das sein.
Mod-Check vom Strand. Jungs, ich brauche eine schnelle Empfehlung
für den Start mit Backend-Entwicklung in C-Sharp. Backend-Web-Anwendung, es gibt nur ASP.NET
Core. Was anderes kannst du nicht verwenden, realistisch betrachtet.
So, also gucken wir uns mal an, was für ein Code generiert wird.
Nein, lasst mich doch mal alle in Ruhe. Ich will den Kram doch einfach nur mal ausbringen.
Also, File. Ja, Console-App, wo ist mein Main?
Hier. Okay, das ist anscheinend, dafür gibt es anscheinend
Framework-Support oder wie? Also, das ist wohl nicht nur syntaktisch
Schnickschnack oder? Oder muss man hier den Output umstellen,
dass es schon decompiled ist? Da bin ich mir jetzt nicht so wirklich sicher.
Scheiß drauf. Keine Ahnung. Wir warten bis Sharp-Lab wieder geht
und dann gucken wir uns das an. Oh, es ist wieder kaputt.
Nee, es ist nicht kaputt. Also, aber an sich ist das Feature wirklich
cool. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wann ich und wo
ich das verwende, aber das ist cool. Was haben die noch so für Beispiele hier?
So, Explorer List Patterns. Okay, das ist, das ist die, ich kann mir,
ich kann mich mit, mit heute nicht mit dieser Switch-Expression, nee, wie heißt das doch?
Switch-Expression. Ich kann mich da bis heute nicht so wirklich
damit anfreunden. Ich hab das, ehrlich gesagt, weiß nicht,
wie es bei euch da aussieht. Ich habe das glaube ich seit der Einführung,
ich will jetzt nicht sagen nie verwendet, aber wahrscheinlich nie verwendet.
Ja, in Rust gibt es so was ähnliches. Ja, genau.
Type-Matching, okay, das kann ich mir vorstellen, aber du kannst das hier mittlerweile brutalst
abgedreht machen in der, in der Switch-Expression. Du kannst ja dann, du kannst ja dann mit Records
irgendwie auch Felder entpacken und sowas, ganz, ganz abgedrehter Shit.
Also, das ist, das ist wirklich High-IQ-Kram. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das in Haskell
entspricht, Haskell entspricht. Aber das hier geht mehr oder weniger so auch
in Rust, wobei es in Rust nicht ganz so abgedreht ist.
Ja, und das ist jetzt halt nur das Beispiel für, für Pattern, ach ja, wer sich fragt,
was das hier ist, das ist für Discarded, also juckt nicht, was da steht.
Das geht mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch bei allen anderen Sachen. Bei Parametern geht
das, bei Lambda-Expressions geht das. Ich glaube, du, bei Parametern, nee, bei Parametern
geht es nicht. Bei Lambda-Expressions geht es aber auf jeden
Fall. Das du sagen kannst, ist egal. Oder Parameter interessiert mich nicht.
Das ist abgedrehter Shit hier. Ja. Das ist wirklich abgedrehter Shit. Also,
da muss ich mich ja noch mal eine Weile mit beschäftigen, bis ich da durchblicke.
Aber das, also was ich richtig cool finde, ist, dass du hier in Trinit auch den Rest
capturen kannst. Ja, also ich stelle mir das zum Beispiel wirklich cool vor. Zum Beispiel,
also ein Anwendungsgebiet, was mir da einfallen würde, ist, mal angenommen, man benutzt FFmpeg
und liest da mit Videoframes ein. So, und die hat man dann als Byte Array, die Daten
von den Videoframes und man möchte dann zum Beispiel checken, ob das ein Keyframe ist
oder so. Ich weiß, das geht mit FFmpeg anders, da kannst du direkt checken lassen, ob das
Packet ein Keyframe ist, aber angenommen möchte ich es von Hand machen. Dann würde ich dann
zum Beispiel checken, ok, erstes ist Discarded, zweites Byte muss sein, keine Ahnung, 8 oder
so und wenn es 8 ist, dann ist es ein Keyframe, das hier hinten ist irgendwie ein Trailer
und das in der Mitte sind die Daten in B, irgendwie sowas. Da kann ich mir das wirklich
ganz gut vorstellen. Wobei, wobei, das jetzt, ich weiß nicht, so wirklich ultra lesbar
ist das jetzt auch nicht, man muss sich da dran gewöhnen auf jeden Fall. Das ist, aber
es ist eine coole Sache, das gefällt mir schon mal. Das ist übrigens auch eine Sache, die
ich bei Microsoft gut finde, wir haben jetzt oft genug geflamed für Windows Shit, aber
die ich bei Microsoft Sachen gut finde, also gerade was sie mit C Sharp und.NET machen
ist, die bauen dort relativ zügig neue Sachen ein, ich meine es gibt ja quasi jedes Jahr
mehr oder weniger jetzt ein neues C Sharp und.NET Release und die Sachen sind meistens
sinnvoll, meistens. Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die ich nicht so geil finde, da muss ich jetzt
aber mal nachdenken, was gab es denn ein paar Sachen, die ich nicht so geil finde, da müssen
wir die letzten Featurelisten mal durchgehen. Also, also, Default Interfaces habe ich noch
nie verwendet, da verstehe ich aber wofür es die gibt, Default Interfaces braucht Microsoft
selbst wahrscheinlich, damit sie ihre eigenen Office Apis gescheit verwenden können. Mod
Check, weg damit. Weg. Aber ansonsten, das meiste ist sinnvoll, was sie eingebaut haben.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch? Ja, wenn man jetzt Explicit Ranges Captchern könnte,
wäre auch mal was anderes. Kann man zwei Sachen Captchern lassen? Hä? Nee, das funktioniert
nicht. Das funktioniert nicht. Das wäre natürlich richtig abgedreht, wenn das funktionieren
würde. Also doppelt, das wäre dann quasi so Regex Wildcard mäßig. Nee, okay, das
funktioniert nicht. Alles klar. Das wäre auch zu abgedreht. So, was haben wir als nächstes
noch? Geht das vielleicht nicht, weil zwischen 9 und 10 nichts ist? Das ist egal. Die Expression
muss funktionieren, auch egal, was ich da als Input reinhau. Also das wird auch anderweitig
nicht funktionieren. Wir können es mal ausprobieren. Weil das muss ja auch für Not. Da steht ja
auch, man darf es nur einmal. Guck, Slice Pattern May Only Be Used Once. Das geht wirklich
nur einmal. Okay, was haben wir als nächstes? Preview Parameter 0 Checking. Okay. War nicht
easy Parameter 0 checken? Deswegen lese ich keine Proposals, das ist mir immer zu lang.
We are putting this feature into the early... Ja, so würde man das aktuell machen. Alternativ
könnte man auch non-nullable Strings nehmen und sich darauf verlassen, dass es nicht
nullable ist. Aber nachdem das ja quasi nur optional ist, musst du trotzdem einen Check
einbauen. Ja, das ist vielleicht so ein Feature, wo ich noch nicht richtig warm geworden bin
und wahrscheinlich auch nicht richtig warm werde. Diese ganze nullable, non-nullable
Geschichte. Die restlichen Erinnerungen finde ich eigentlich immer ziemlich gut. Aber das
ist so ein Ding. Ja. Was hältst du von Windows 11? Abstand? Nix. Gar nichts. Grausam. Also
it's quite common to validate... Okay, das Copy pasten wir uns jetzt mal. Schauen wir
uns das mal an. Also Static void kegw. Und das checken wir jetzt, ob das String null
ist. Also kegw null. So. Und da sollte es jetzt eigentlich eine Argument Null Exception
geben. Jaja, das ist alt. Wobei das so alt ist, das gar nicht. Dass man es, genau, dass
man es is null sagen kann, ist relativ neu. Früher musste man so machen. Und wisst ihr,
was noch neuer ist, dass man is not null sagen kann? Nuts. Das ist glaube ich erst seit
C Sharp 10 soweit, dass das geht. Kann man es is void? Nein, das geht nicht. Das wäre
auch ziemlich sinnig und unsinnig in dem Fall. Okay, so. Und das neue ist jetzt was? Aushufezeichen,
Aushufezeichen. Moment, wohin muss das? Nicht an den Typ, sondern an den Namen hinten dran.
Ich mein, das is insofern nice, weil du dir halt den Standard Null Check sparst. Zeig
mal her, das soll jetzt das gleiche. Value cannot be null Parameter S. Okay, die machen
im Prinzip nix anderes. Das können wir mal kompilieren und uns angucken. Build. Das ist
bestimmt reine Compiler Magic. Das ist bestimmt reine Compiler Magic. Debug. Schauen wir uns
das mal an. Zack. Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal die Compile angucken. Windows, komm gib
Gas. Das hältst ja so net aus, das ist so langsam. Hallo. Main. Okay, meine Settings
sind Müll. Das ist garantiert nur Compiler Magic. Das ist doch garantiert nur Compiler
Magic. Das muss doch. Das kann ja net sein, dass das in der Runtime drinne ist, dieser
Check im Leben nicht. Die Runtime geht für x-beliebig andere Sprachen, auch wo das garantiert
nicht die Fault ist. Das Ding hier, das die Compile Ding macht, irgendwelche Magic Geschichten.
Guck sie mir L-View an. Was hat der Chat gesagt, soll ich heute ein DN Spy? Okay, Download.
Wo gibt's das? Gibt's da keine fertigen Packages? Doch Latest Release. Latest Release, Windows
64. Holder..p kann das auch, ich weiß aber nicht wo. Können wir uns aber gleich angucken.
Vielleicht ist es damit aber einfacher. Geh unter Options auf die Compiler. Okay. Ja,
das macht doch an der Windows Geschwindigkeit nichts Chat, wenn ich was Neues installiere.
Die N-Spy. Geh mit ihm. Auf. Okay, jetzt schauen wir uns das mal an. Programm, Main.
Okay. What the fuck? Wo geht's überhaupt los? Was? Kann das sein, dass der das wegoptimiert
hat, weil ich nichts mache? Kann das sein? Muss ich so noch, muss ich noch mal so machen?
Keine Ahnung. String. Return. Kekwe. Build. Row if nur. Ach hier. Das macht er da draus.
Ah, if argument gleich gleich null. Throw Parameter Name. Okay. Argument null exception
Parameter Name. Okay, also das rappt er quasi in sowas hier. Okay, das ist reine Compiler
Magic. Interessant. Und wie mache ich das jetzt hier mit? Was soll ich da? Options und
dann was? Die Compiler. Ach hier, das muss ich wegmachen. Ah, jetzt sehe ich das hier
auch. Okay, nice. Was oder Windows Elview? Der Elview ist halt die Fivehead Variante.
Das, das hier will ich haben. Genau. Ja. Jetzt sieht man's. Okay, verstehe. Also reine Compiler
Magic. Tja, finde ich das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Chat, was sagt ihr dazu? Ich finde es nicht
verkehrt. Ich meine ganz im Ernst, so Checks machst du relativ oft. Ist halt die Sache,
braucht es dafür wirklich so eine neue Syntax? Hätte man das nicht mit einem Attribut machen
können? Ich meine in Dotnet stehen die doch eh auf Attribute. Hätte man nicht sowas
machen können? Moment nicht so. Hätte man nicht sowas machen können? Ich meine, das
wäre doch auch gegangen, oder? Neue random Syntax, ja. Nee, das sieht kacke aus, findest
du? Ich finde das eigentlich ganz gut mit dem Attribut davor. Ich meine, was ist? Chat,
es hat bestimmt seinen Grund, warum sie kein Attribut genommen haben, ne? Gehe ich mal
von aus. Also Microsoft durchdenkt die Dinger ja immer. Aber was findet ihr schöner von
der Syntax her? S, Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen oder Null als Attribut davor? Zu lang? Warum
nicht ein Keyword? Sowas wie required oder so vielleicht, hä? Was haltet ihr davon,
das wäre doch cool. Oder? Ich meine, oder man könnte sowas machen. Man könnte es ausschreiben
so irgendwie. Keine Ahnung. Required wäre auch ein Nullstring. Das stimmt wohl. Und
Parameter, die keinen Defaultwert haben, sind ja immer Required. Ja, das würde wahrscheinlich
nicht so gut passen. Ja gut, dann bleibt wahrscheinlich nichts anderes übrig als sowas. Double Bang
Operator. Wie nennen sie das? Wie nennen sie das jetzt offiziell? Wie heißt dieser Operator?
Hat es schon einen Namen? Bang, Bang, Bang, Operator, der Bang, Bang, Operator. Ja, der
Gangbang Operator. Hat wer eine Empfehlung, welche Programmierspal am meisten Sinn macht
zu lernen? Definitiv nicht C++. C++ ist glaube ich der größte Kack, den man überhaupt nur
haben kann. Ich sage ja immer, wenn man nicht genaue Vorstellungen hat, was man machen will,
am besten Frontend Browser, Texteditator, JavaScript, HTML, CSS. Da sieht man direkt, was passiert
und Frontend brauchst du eh immer. Kommst im Frontend gar nicht rum. So, was haben wir
als nächstes? Also, die erzählen noch ein bisschen was zu. Ja, das sind irgendwelche.
Was zum? Was gibt das? Was gibt das, wenn es fertig ist? Ach, das geht nicht. Ah, das
ist erlaubt. Okay, alles klar. Okay, okay, okay. Dann ist gut, wenn es nicht erlaubt
ist. Weil, sag mal so, das kannst du ja. Ach, keine Ahnung. Wie findest du Proton-Mail?
Kein Schimmer habe ich noch nie verwendet. Ref String, in String, out String. Das ist
auch so neues. Die Sharp fragt mich nicht 10 Feature oder 9 Feature. Nicht out, sondern
diese Geschichte hier, das habe ich glaube ich auch so oder nicht verwendet. Jetzt wird
es aber abgedreht. Was ist denn in String? Da müsste ich nachgucken. Ich bin mir da gar
nicht so sicher. Das sind Sachen, die sie eingeführt haben für besonders speichereffizienten
Kram. Das kam so zu der Gleichzeit, wo sie Span und Memory und sonst was eingeführt
haben, dass du, hauptsächlich haben sie das für ASP.NET Core eingeführt damals, dass
sie ihr Web-Framework schneller kriegen und haben halt gesagt, das machen sie quasi auch
verfügbar für alle normalen Sterblichen. Keine Ahnung, da müsste ich selbst nachgucken.
Meine Ref ist klar, Ref gibt es schon ewig. Out gibt es auch schon relativ lang, aber
den, keine Ahnung. Extending ist Null. Hör mal auf. Ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben.
Okay, also weiter gehts. Das mit dem Frontend ist legit, ja Frontend ist das Beste zum Anfang.
Man kommt eh nicht dran vorbei und man kann mit einem Browser und einem Texteditor starten
und man sieht direkt was passiert. So, also hätten wir das hier uns angeschaut, alles
gut. Eigentlich nice, warum man irgendwie diese Gangbang Sündtags braucht. Ja, mir fällt
jetzt aber auch nichts wirklich Gescheites als Alternative ein und ich glaube, Microsoft
hat sich da wirklich Gedanken drum gemacht, weil generell in der Vergangenheit, finde
ich, hat man schon gesehen, Microsoft macht sich bei 90 Sharp Features meistens Gedanken
und kommt auf das, sag mal, schlüssigste Ergebnis, wie sie es dann implementieren.
Also die Leute sind schon clever, die das machen, da gibt es nix. Okay, weiter gehts.
Das war's schon. Wie, das ist alles? Wie? Wait a minute. GG Eats. Okay.
Das sind, ich dachte, da stehen auch 2, 3 Sachen mehr drin.
Neues, die Sharp Features sind deutlich nachvollziehbarer als alles, was in C++. Ja, also ganz ehrlich,
C++ ist da wirklich kein Maßstab. C++ ist jetzt schon Abfahrt, wir hoch 10 und das
nächste zählt, der nächste C++ Standard macht das Abfahrt, wir hoch 11. Also C++ ist
schon nicht mehr rettbar eigentlich. Ich mein, die haben jetzt ja immerhin, ich glaube im
letzten C++ Standard haben sie es doch geschafft, dass es jetzt endlich Module gibt. Die Sache
ist halt die, damit bräuchtest du wahrscheinlich keine Hatterfiles mehr. Glaube ich zumindest.
Und die Sache ist halt die, ich glaube nicht, dass ich das jemals durchsetzen wird, weil
die C++ Leute halt ultra auf Hatterfiles stehen. Und die 30 Milliarden Libraries, die
gibt in C++ jemals alle Hatterfiles. Zumal, du wirst eh auf ganz vielen Plattformen auf
absehbare Zeit keinen Compiler haben, der C++ 20 vollständig implementiert. Also C++ ist
mal wirklich kompletter Abfahrt. Moin VirusBLN.
Ne, alles geht nicht. Alles geht nicht, das wär zu einfach. Static Klassenvariablen kannst
du nicht anlegen inline im Header. Das ist das erste, was mir jetzt einfällt. C++ ist
genauso schlimm wie in Battlefield 20 240. Also wenn ich raten müsste, in was Frostbite
programmiert ist, würde ich mal an C++ denken. Ey, wisst ihr was, die Leute, die haben sich
das freiwillig ausgesucht, ich hab da kein Mitleid. Hauptsache Battlefield 5 angekündigt,
ja. Aber die haben es ja nicht angekündigt, das ist ja alles nur Spekulation, wobei da
schon was dran sein wird. Ziemlich sicher.
Ja, das ist übrigens auch ein riesen Vorteil mit JavaScript, CSS und Frontendgeschiss anzufangen.
Du findest so viele kostenlose Tutorials, Webcasts, Konferenztalks, Doku-Geschichten,
gute bezahlte Kurse, alles. Du kannst JavaScript wirklich von Null an heute an jeder Ecke lernen,
also das ist wirklich auch ein weiterer Pluspunkt dafür.
Der Level Editor, ja Moment, du meinst den Venice Unleashed Level Editor, der ist in
sich abgeschrieben, wie der offizielle EA Frostbite Editor ist, keine Ahnung. Was man
sonst für eine Game Engine nutzen soll, ja. C, C++. Man könnte alternativ auch es so
machen wie Unity, ich finde Unity macht das sinnvoll. Unity selber ist in C++, aber du
kannst Unity in C sharp programmieren, die übersetzen das dann in C++. Oder du machst
wie der Rollercoaster Tycoon Dude und programmierst alles in Assembler. Ich gehe davon aus, dass
wir in Zukunft was in Rust sehen werden, aber ich finde Rust ist auch zu kompliziert für
sowas. Bei Spielen kommt es ja nicht so sehr darauf an, dass das alles super krass gecheckt
ist, dass es keine Overflows und sonst was gibt. Der Kram muss funktionieren und locker
von der Hand gehen, was Rust auch nicht macht. Deswegen finde ich macht Unity am besten.
Das macht Unity aber. Soweit ich weiß übersetzt Unity, oder ich weiß nicht, wobei ich glaube
da stimmen sie nicht. Ich glaube Unity übersetzt nicht deinen ganzen C sharp Code, aber Unity
muss ja irgendwie deinen C sharp Code attachen zu dem unterliegenden C++ Zeug, oder? Also
wie sollen die das sonst machen? Die machen invoke oder was? Ich dachte eigentlich die
übersetzen das. Warum mögen so viele Rust? Es hat seinen Grund, dass Mozilla damit viel
für Firefox gemacht hat, weil Rust die einzige Programmiersprache ist, die es gibt, also
die mir einfällt, zumindest die Geschwindigkeit und Sicherheit in einem hat ohne Runtimechecks
zu brauchen dafür. In C++ zum Beispiel oder in C oder in irgendeiner anderen Programmiersprache,
die komplett unmanaged ist, das schützt dich keiner davor. Beispiel mal genommen du hast
ein Array mit 5, du hast ein dynamisches Array, was jetzt gerade zufälligerweise 10 initialisierte
Elemente hast und du greifst auf Element 15 zu. So, dann crash dir das Ding in C und C++.
Im Zweifelfall hast du irgendeine Sicherheitslücke. In C sharp geht das nicht. In C sharp gibt
es einen Runtimecheck, ob du auf einen gültigen Index zugreifst. Der Runtimecheck braucht
natürlich, frisst natürlich ein bisschen Performance. So und Rust macht es halt so,
dass sie das schon zur Compile-Time erkennen können solche Dinger. Das ist halt sehr clever.
Rust checkt zum Beispiel auch, ob du Threads hast, die nicht garantiert sind, dass sie
so lange leben, wie dass du dann drauf zugreifst und solche Geschichten. Also das ist wirklich
sehr, sehr schlau. Ja, wie es im Detail aussieht, keine Ahnung. Es kann durchaus sein, dass
das Beispiel jetzt nicht so schlau gewählt war. Aber zum Beispiel, also was Rust auf jeden
Fall zur Compile-Zeit abfallen kann, ist zu gucken, ob dein Pointer Null ist. Pointer
in den klassischen Varianten gibt es ja in Rust gar nicht. Weil in Rust machen sie es
so, wenn du eine Variable hast und eine Referenz von der Variable nimmst, dann wird das komplett
durch die Lebenszeit deines kompletten Codes gecheckt, ob du den nicht irgendwann frei
gibst und woanders drauf zugreifen könntest, wenn er nicht mehr gültig ist. Also Rust
ist die einzige Programmiersprache, die mir einfällt, die quasi es schafft zu garantieren,
dass du keinen Security-Müll programmierst und gleichermaßen nicht übermäßig viele
Runtime-Checks brauchst, die sich negativ auf die Performance auswirken. Dementsprechend
kämpft man am Anfang auch gegen Rust, gegen den Rust-Compiler. Also ich hab ja, als Rust
relativ neu war, noch bei 1.0 und auch vor 1.0, glaub ich, mich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt
und das war wirklich schon gewöhnungsbedürftig. Du brauchst so 1-2 Wochen erstmal, dass du
überhaupt nicht permanent abgefuckt bist, weil dir der Rust-Compiler sagt, das geht
zu nicht. Moin, DakuXTV, 22 Monate, Massive. Ich hab noch nie was von dir gelesen, fällt
mir zumindest jetzt grad nicht auf, aber Dankeschön für 22 Monate. Hypersubscription, du bist
ja schon richtig lange dabei. Massive. Wobei, das stimmt nicht. Natürlich sagt mir der
Name was, doch, jetzt. Zumindest billig mir das jetzt ein. Doch, ich glaube, ich hab's
schon gelesen. Nicht, dass ich mich jetzt komplett im Kopf und Kragen rede oder so.
Aber ich glaube, du schreibst nicht viel, oder? Ich muss mal kurz gucken. Oh, 458 Nachrichten,
okay. Na gut, da haben andere Spammer deutlich mehr. Das ist gar nicht so viel in 22 Monaten.
Aber trotzdem, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ja, das stimmt wohl. Also ich würde auch sagen,
also wenn man eine Weile Rust programmiert hat, man macht sich um viel mehr Sachen Gedanken,
die man vorher einfach hingenommen hat. Ich würde so weit gehen und sagen, ein bisschen
Rust macht einen zu einem besseren Entwickler. Ja, genau, diese ganze Borrow-Checker-Geschichte,
das ist wirklich feifett. Wir könnten wirklich mal ein bisschen Rust machen. Ich hab das
alles schon wieder verlernt wahrscheinlich. Wenn du bei der Arbeit eine Software entwickeln
müsst, zum Beispiel ein Ticketsystem, dann würde ich was nehmen, was es schon fertig
gibt und kein Ticketsystem selbst programmieren. Okay, ohne eine Erfassung für irgendwelche
Artikel. Welche Technologie würdest du da einsetzen? Web, C-Sharp oder sonstiges? Na
ja, ihr kennt meine Vorlieben. Wir haben ja schon Sachen gemacht von, wir haben sogar
mal ein bisschen Rust gemacht vor zwei Jahren oder so im Stream. Von ein bisschen Rust bis
Go. Wir haben sogar Ruby-Sachen schon mal im Stream. Wir haben jetzt viele Sachen gemacht.
Ihr wisst, ich persönlich bin C-Sharp-Fan und ganz im Ernst, ich würde wahrscheinlich
eine Mischung aus Web, Frontend und ASP.NET Core Backend nehmen. Fertig. Du bist seit
Quad 4 dabei, Pock. Auch als 15-jähriger Hip-Hop auf YouTube gewesen damals. Oder warst
du da schon älter? Weil wir hatten es vorhin davon. Hat jemand geschrieben, er ist jetzt
25. Das heißt, ich wusste, er war 14 oder so, als er angefangen hat, meine Videos zu
gucken. Also ich würde wahrscheinlich ASP.NET Core verwenden und irgendein Web, Frontend
bauen, was sich die Sachen dynamisch zieht. Zumal das ja auch nicht wirklich wichtig ist,
öffentlich im Internet zu sein und gut durchsuchbar zu sein. Du bist auch 25, wir haben sehr viele
25-Jährige hier. Wie viel RAM ziehen deine ganzen Chrome Tabs? Das gucken wir jetzt mal
schnell. Kann man das überhaupt gescheit erkennen in Windows? 1G, das ist aber nicht
viel. Ich hätte gedacht, das ist mehr. Das ist aber nicht so viel. 1G nur? Was ist denn
da los? Ja wahrscheinlich sind die meisten Tabs entladen. Wahrscheinlich sind die meisten
Tabs entladen. Guck mal, die Tabs sind gar nicht geladen hier. Wenn ich die Tabs lade...
Sekunde. Nee, ich lade jetzt nicht alle. Wenn ich die Tabs lade, dann brauche ich wahrscheinlich
8G oder sowas. Übrigens, warum braucht man, braucht man eine VM im Hintergrund? Ähm,
11, 11% CPU Last, hier passiert nichts. Was macht denn meine VM im Hintergrund? Wie macht
man überhaupt den Task Manager auf? Windows 11. Ah, der Windows Defender zieht die ganze
Rechenleistung. Okay, nice. GG Eats, Windows Defender. Umfrage, umfrage, 25, ja, nein.
Das ist eine Umfrage. Wir können davon ausgehen, die meisten Leute sind zwischen 22 und 28,
wenn sie damals YouTube bei mir geguckt haben. Anders geht es ja gar nicht. Wobei hier jetzt
auch viele ältere sind, das weiß ich auf Twitch. Wir haben ja sogar Leute auf Twitch,
man hält das gar nicht für möglich, die älter sind als ich. Das soll vorkommen. Und
Leute sogar hier auf Twitch. Du bist 79, das glaube ich dir nicht, dass du 79 bist. Und
sogar Leute, die hier auf Twitch gucken, aber YouTube gar nicht kennen. 79-jähriger Rocket-League-Streamer.
Sag mal, Virus, bist du der Virus, der Freund vom Tyler oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Ich meine, der Name ist wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht so unique, dass es nur einen Virus gibt.
Nee, das bist du nicht. Dann hätte er sein können. Die Welt ist ja klein. Die Welt ist
ja klein. Machst du mal eine Tour durch deinen Garten im Schnee? Nochmal. 18, ja 18 ist ja
noch richtig, ist ja noch richtig Summa, Alter hier. Leute, wir sind fertig mit C-Sharp-Features,
weil das war alles. Mehr gibt es nicht, ist diese drei Dinger. Darf ich, Leute, darf
ich meine Windows, darf ich meine Windows-VM jetzt endlich löschen? Wie viel Platz haben
wir denn eigentlich? Dieser Müll. Nee, ich glaube, ich brauch die noch. Ich mach die
aber aus. Ich glaube, ich brauche die noch, weil die nächsten Windows-Geschichten und
die nächste Preview-Version und so muss ja auch noch getestet werden. Nein, heute garantiert
kein Rust mehr. Vielleicht am Wochenende, wenn ich ausgeruht bin und mein Hirn frei
genug ist dafür. Haben wir noch irgendein Video, was wir uns reinziehen können vor
dem Betgetime? New Home-Automation, no. Alter, Windows, please click registrieren. Oh nee,
den gucke ich nicht. Von dem haben wir ein Video geguckt, das war so heftig, von dem
haben wir ein Video geguckt, warum er kein Firefox mehr verwendet und dann wollte er
den Gnome-Browser verwenden, obwohl wir schon direkt im Video gesagt haben, das wird nichts
und dann hat er den Gnome-Browser verwendet und hat ein Video danach gemacht und gesagt,
der Gnome-Browser ist kacke. NS-Panel gibt es gerade für 35 Euro auf Aliexpress. Okay,
da muss ich jetzt mal gucken. Nein, kann ich die einfach raus? Die Stream-VM, nee, Vorgast
müssen wir anmachen. Die Stream-VM, die können wir mal komplett ausschalten, die brauchen
wir gar nicht mehr. Wir gucken jetzt mal Aliexpress schnell, weil so ein NS-Panel wollte ich mir
schon eine Weile bestellen, einfach nur weil es geht. Ich habe dafür keinen konkreten
Anwendungszweck, aber ihr kennt mich, ich kaufe gerne mal random China-Chinesen-Zeug einfach
ums zu haben. Aber es ist Aliexpress-Logik, wahrscheinlich kostet es, wenn ich ein anderes
Fenster aufmache, weniger. Aliexpress-Logik versteht man eh nicht.
Ja, so ein NS-Panel wollte ich mir schon eine Weile bestellen, einfach ums zu haben und
ein bisschen damit rumzuspielen. Nicht wirklich, um da täglich damit irgendwas zu benutzen
oder so. Ich finde es von der Idee her ganz cool und einfach ein bisschen mit rumbasteln.
Also, Bundle, EU, US, nee nee, EU-Bundle. US ist hochkant, ist auch schon fail-less.
So, EU-Bundle. Chips from Germany? Wie? Kostenloser Versand? Okay. Wait a minute.
Warum kriegen die China-Chinesen das hin und die meisten anderen Shops nicht? Und es ist
auch noch relativ günstig. Erstmal... Nee, nee, Quatsch. So viel bestellen wir nicht.
Das ist kein Scam, glaube ich nicht. Das ist... Okay, vielleicht ist das doch Scam. Ich meine,
ist shop 110 3 3 1 9 38 vielleicht ist es doch scam aber aber es gibt auch keine
kundenbewertungen so aber 0,0 ist aber die sache ist halt die das sieht alles auf
aliexpress so scammy aus und in der regel kriegst du bei aliexpress easy dein
geld wieder wenn sie dich scam normalerweise kostet es ungefähr doppelte
ja ja du hast bestellt und kam es an oder ist er unterwegs ja normalerweise
kostet sich immer 56 71 ja warum die da billiger sind vielleicht ist es ein
scam shop keine ahnung man weiß es nicht ich war in der shop hat null bewertung
das ns panel hat null kundenbewertung hier der shop hat null bewertung kontakt
da muss mich einloggen oder das kann durchaus und der shop name ist halt auch
nicht sonderlich vertrauenswürdig vielleicht ist es auch scam bin ich mal
gespannt ob das ankommt weiß nicht wer bestellt hat
ist das einfach ein android system nee das ist ein esp 32 mit mit firmen wir
von denen da gibt es da gibt es ganz coole projekte zum beispiel gibt es auf
github ein projekt für das ns panel dass das ding so aussieht wie dein
home assistant dashboard das da nee was ist denn jetzt das da
aber die sache ist halt die es ist trotzdem nicht ein home assistant
dashboard deswegen das ist eigentlich ist es nicht wirklich sinnig finde ich
dadurch dass es halt kein browser zur anzeige benutzt sondern das explizit
jeder mist quasi rein programmiert werden muss es sieht halt auch nur so aus
es ist halt nicht das normale home assistant dashboard deswegen ist es
schwierig also ich glaube nicht dass ich meine mein haus hier irgendwie damit
ausrüsten würde aber vom ansatz her finde ich die dinge halt cool deswegen
will ich mir eins bestellen einfach zum haben und ausprobieren das ist dein
projekt nice wie ist das denn sind sich das irgendwie von von meinem dashboard
was oder also so wie ich das verstanden habe ist das quasi komplett
unabhängig davon es sieht halt einfach nur so aus wie das home assistant
dashboard das hat mit dem home assistant dashboard nichts zu tun
du hast quasi bedienelemente die du enden kannst die aussehen wie die
loveless elemente aber es hat nichts mit meinem home assistant dashboard zu tun
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe wenn ich dann sagt das das stimmt nicht
scroll mal zur config übrigens finde das richtig nice dass wir hier random so
viele leute immer im stream im stream haben den hüpfer haben auch manchmal am
start wobei ich immer noch weiß ob er hüpfer oder halb war oder so heißt der
waldetudo prokramiert also finde ich finde ich nice sammelt sich hier alles
irgendwie auf twitch von mir im chat config zeigt mal her config
configuration
aha
was ist denn jetzt los wurde wurde wurde ich irgendwie gehostet und habe es
nicht gesehen jetzt wo ich jetzt wo ich ins bett gehe oder wie
captain samy hat mich gerätet dankeschön captain samy
poc
samar hatte ich nicht mal in der anzeige für hostings und freud's wo ist
denn die hin
normalerweise habe ich eine anzeige aber da kann ich für den rate so was
verstehen geblieben jetzt ja genau also jojo ich ich glaube ich habe es
gecheckt man braucht eine jammel config dafür so was hier boah das ist
natürlich dann auch schon wieder messer 5 hat aber es hat gewisse
ähnlichkeiten zu zu haumus ist den config also ich werde es damit mal
ausprobieren wenn das funktioniert wenn uns die china wenn uns die china chinesen
nicht scammen
schicke uns weiter wenn du oft ist ja ich gehe ich gehe gleich oft in zehn
minuten ja ich suche mir jemand raus ich suche mir
jemand raus der gehostet wird also wenn wenn uns die china chinesen nicht
scammen dann habe ich demnächst ein ich werde es wahrscheinlich mal ausprobieren
gleich wenn ich den stream auf hab also wenn ich wenn ich oft bin wenn ich den
stream aus habe ich werde es wahrscheinlich mal probieren weil es
kostet aktuell nur die hälfte und es schippt aus germany und wenn ich die
scam bezahlt der aliexpress die das geld zurück also die sind normalerweise
nicht sehr tolerant was gescammer angeht auf aliexpress probiere ich probiere das
mal aus mal schauen
so chat gab es gab sonst so irgendwas voraussichtliche lieferzeit nie
voraussichtliche lieferzeit ist 1 bis 10 tage ich mein shop 1100 3 3 1 0 8 3
1038 klingt jetzt ich gebe zu es klingt nicht vertrauensweckend aber es man
darf nicht vergessen es ist aliexpress übrigens das ist auch der einzige
grund warum wish überhaupt nur irgendwie ansatzweise erfolgreich ist
weil dem normalen besteller aliexpress zu sehr nach scam aussieht das
eigentliche problem ist ja dass wish viel mehr scam ist als aliexpress gut das
hier sieht jetzt schon ein bisschen nach scam aus ganz ehrlich
aber aliexpress ich habe wirklich nur gute erfahrungen bisher mitgemacht und
wish ist eigentlich viel mehr scam sieht aber nicht so aus und aliexpress ist
nicht scam und sieht nach scam aus wisst ihr wisst ihr wie ich mein
sag mal das ist auch besit sehr günstig
aktuell was haben wir denn sonst noch so in diesem shop
das ist bestimmt gar maß alter der shop shop ansehen
wish sieht nicht so sehr nach scam aus für den normalen käufer wie wie
aliexpress ne aber wir wissen dass wir scam ist oftmals
scheiß drauf übrigens leute eine sache noch bevor ich bevor ich mich vergrümel
gleich ja klassisch klassischer wish eine sache bevor ich gleich abhaut hat
jemand von euch einen label drucker den man über ein web interface steuern kann
aliexpress ja gut das kann schon mal passieren aber wie gesagt ich habe
bisher eigentlich ausnahmslos gute erfahrungen gemacht und dort wo sie es
einmal nicht zweimal zweimal wo sie es nicht hinbekommen haben habe ich bei
aliexpress anstandslos mein geld zurück bekommen also mit dem paypal käufer
schutz habe ich mich mehr rum geärgert als mit aliexpress und das obwohl man
eigentlich sagen könnte den chinesen ist das doch wurscht
was für github issues ein label drucker
so was hier
wo man sich etiketten trocken kann wo man zum beispiel kabel mit beschriftet
oder schubladen mit beschriftet oder sowas so ein label drucker den man
halt einfach ins wlan hängt im browser drauf geht und dann ein tipp was man
drucken will und auf drucken drückt sowas meine ich
hattest du bis vorm umzug also ich habe jetzt ein tragbar oder stationär gut
die dinger sind so klein die kannst du meistens tragen ich habe ein aber da
musst du auf dem auf dem gerät also ich habe so ein ding ich habe den ganz
billigen dümo weiß ich wie die dinger heißen zu ganz billigen so ein hier habe
ich
das video kenne ich das video kenne ich der macht es mit einem ganz abgedrehten
controller also das ding erfüllt voll und ganz das was es machen soll aber das
tippen auf dem display ist wirklich abfuck deswegen hätte ich gerne einen
den ich am besten über den browser steuern kann ich will überhaupt kein
drucker treiber installieren müssen oder sonst was einfach per browser drauf und
gut ist rosa p touch mit der app steuerbar ja mir wäre es am liebsten ich
kann einfach im browser auf die adresse vom label printer und kann ausdrucken
ohne dass ich eine app brauche ohne dass ich treiber installieren muss oder
sonst was ich mein was man machen könnte ist man kann man kauft sich ein der
steuerbar ist über kups oder so und der linux und dann hänge ich in raspberry
pie dran und über den druck ich dann über über browser irgendwie das das
geht ja auch aber man schöner schöner wäre es wenn das fix und fertig wäre
ich weiß ich ob ich immer so abgedrehte vorstellungen habe aber warum gibt es
so was nicht ein label drucker der ins wlan kommt und ich gehe auf das web
interface und sage hier label 123 drucken das ist doch nicht so zu abwegig
die vorstellung oder findest du seltener aber eigentlich ist es so doch viel
besser gut die 015 user die wollen wahrscheinlich wirklich auf der
tastatur tippen am label drucker oder eben über die app ja ach keine ahnung so
leute wie können wir denn mal hausten
komm wir hausten wir hausten ich weiß wenn wir hausten im bettel viel dem
den bettel viel drei spieler der immer noch auf twitch die immer noch auf
twitter viel drei fahne hoch hält multi multi language stream deutsch eng also
er kann auch der kann auch deutsch steht auch hier usde ja den gucke ich auch
nebenbei immer den habe ich nebenbei immer auf monitor auf wenn er spielt ich
will bettel viel drei sounds entspannend nebenbei fragt mich nicht warum ich
bettel viel drei sounds entspannend finde aber ich will bettel viel drei
sounds entspannend wenn die nebenbei laufen wir reden den jetzt war alles gut
dieser kanal richtet sich an erwachsene leute
ho seid brav stellt euch nicht so also nicht so schlimm an
dico keff danke für den sub ich schaue jetzt ab
raid ist raus wir sehen uns beim nächsten stream bis denn zu